[موسيقى]
هذا الشاب يتجنب مغادره
منزله اعيش في حاله مستمره من التوتر
والقلق اقضي وقتي وانا امسح مكان تواجدي
على موقع تيليغرام كي اتجنب ان يقبض
علي يتابع على تليغرام الشبكات العديده
التي تبين مكان وجود المسؤولين عن التجنيد
الذين يسوقون الناس بالقوه
احيانا الناس كالكلاب ويقترحون الان ايضا
اغلاق الحسابات المصرفيه حتى لا نتمكن من
شراء حتى الخبز في حال ذهابنا الى الجبهه
يمكننا نظريا كسب المال ولكن من يدري متى
سنعود هذا في حال عدنا هم يرسلون الى
القتال اشخاصا عاديين ليست لديهم مهارات
عسكريه ومن المستحيل ان يتعلموها خلال شهر
واحد هنا في دونتسك يحرص هؤلاء الجنود على
تبديد المخاوف اثناء التدريب نحن ايضا لم
نكن نعرف فعل اي شيء لم يكن لدى معظمنا اي
فكره عن ماهيه الحرب لكننا اليوم نقدم
المساعده والدعم النفسي لجميع رجالنا
الامر مغاير لفكره انهم يعطون كزيا
وبندقيه اليه ويرسلون الى الجبهه كي تموت
يتم تدريب هؤلاء الرجال لمده لا تقل عن
عشره اسابيع قبل ارسالهم الى
القتال بسبب انخفاض عدد الاوكرانيين الذين
يلتحقون بالقتال يريد هؤلاء الضباط اظهار
صوره مطمئنه عن الجيش لجذب عدد اكبر من
المجندين
سمعت ان بعض الاماكن كانت تعلن انها لا
تزال سوفيتيه ليس هنا والحمد لله يحدث في
كتائب اخرى الا يعرف البعض حتى قاده
وحداتهم هنا يمكنهم الذهاب لرؤيه القائد
ومصافحته والتحدث معه كصديق يتجهون نحو
الجبهه مع مقاتل تم تجنيده مؤخرا مرت
ثلاثه اشهر على انضمام الى الجيش من ضمنها
فتره التدريب انطباعاتي عن هذه الفتره
ايجابيه جدا التقيت بالكثير من الشرفاء
الذين يمكن الاعتماد عليهم انضم هذا الرجل
الى الجيش طوعا لكنه يعرف اخرين لا يرغبون
في ذلك رؤيه مثل هذه المقاطع المصوره التي
يظهر فيها المسؤولون عن التجنيد وهم
يقودون الاشخاص بالقوه الى الشاحنات لا
تساعد حقا في عمليه التعبئه عندما يرى
رجال عاديون مثل هذه المشاهد فسيشعر
بالخوف اكثر بدانا حمله للتجنيد كي ينضم
الناس الى الجيش طوعيا نريد ان نجذب اولئك
الذين ينضمون الى الجيش مصدر للرزق لكن
التعبئه ضروريه وخاصه للذين لا يعرفون
ماذا يريدون عندها يصبح الاجبار ضروريا
سالناه عن اولئك الذين لا يريدون الخدمه
كذلك الشاب الذي التقيناه في كيف يض سيخجل
في النهايه سنربح عندما ننتصر ويعم السلام
من سيكون وماذا سيكون
موقعه بعض النخب السياسيه تشكك في فاعليه
مثل هذه الاساليب ويحتد النقاش في
البرلمان حول تجديد عمليات التعبئه لا
يمكننا في اوكرانيا اللجوء الى التعبئه
القمعيه القصريه سيوافق الناس على تجنيدهم
لكن في المقابل يجب ان يحصلوا على التدريب
اللازم وفي انتظار ان يصبحوا مؤهلين يمكن
للذين يعرفون استخدام الاسلحه ان ياخذوا
بشكل طارئ
مكانهم نواب البرلمان اعادوا نسخه اوليه
من نص قانون حول التعبئه الى مجلس الوزراء
لاعاده صياغتها والخلاف محتدم حول هذه
المساله ما اثار استياء هذا النائب وهو
مجند في الوقت نفسه في كل مره اعود فيها
الى كياف واسمع هذه المناقشات اشعر
بالمراره ماذا لو تحدثنا عن ذلك لشهر اخر
نحن في اوكرانيا ونقاتل من اجل استقلالنا
لا توجد حلول سهله يطالبون بارسال المزيد
من رجال الشرطه الى الجبهه ولكن هناك
الكثير منهم يقاتلون حاليا لا يجب ان نسمح
لانفسنا ان نقوم بالعاب
سياسيه هذه السيده
حا في الشهر
السابع زوجها يقاتل في الخط الامامي على
الجبهه يمنحها الماء فرصه ثمينه
للاسترخاء عندما اكون في المنزل وحدي ولا
يكون لدي ما افعله وليس لدي اي موعد اشعر
بالحزن انها بنت سنسميه ماريانا زوجي را
شكلي وانا حامل خلال الديو فقط تتحدث مع
زوجها كل يوم تقريبا لكن الاخبار تكون
مقلقه
[موسيقى]
احيانا تستعد للولاده بمفردها كنت اتمنى
ان نكون معا اثناء الولاده اخر مره
التقينا فيها كانت في الصيف لن يسمح له
بالمجيء حتى لقضاء عطله نهايه الاسبوع
فليس لديهم ما يكفي من المقاتلين يقاتل
زوجها في واحده من اكثر المناطق
سخونه عندما اذهب في مهمه اتصل بها
واخبرها انه يتعذر الاتصال بي خلال يومين
او ثلاثه ايام ستقلق علي بشده ولذلك فان
مساله التعبئه امر بالغ الاهميه بالنسبه
الينا وقد حان الوقت للمجتمع ان يدرك ذلك
عودوا الى رشدكم وتعالوا لمساعدتنا فالوضع
صعب بسبب النقص لم يحصل معظم الاوكرانيين
المرابطين على الجبهه في العام الماضي على
اجازه لاكثر من عشره ايام